[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know a lot of people reached out to
us they wanted to be on the show and
sometimes you have to turn people down
and this guy just kept persisting and
persisting and he apparently has nothing
going on right now and uh he is a friend
of the show so we do him a favor a solid
maybe for his career
adam sandler the uh happy madison uh
co-founder or founder and uh they
produced home team
recently recently the number one film on
netflix and it's
going well
huge movie that you're in yeah i know
it's a blockbuster thank you i just
never asked off but i i never get back
and money from any of your movies
why why is it those are the best moments
in your career when you get the phone
call guess what's in the mail
four years later and they slip you
you know two 300 bucks what's the
biggest check you ever received back end
of a movie
i don't know i i
really uh like it just kind of i get
these calls out of nowhere just like hey
you got a big check the other day from
50 first day somebody really
i'll take that and then
right when i'm about to grab it the
wife's hand goes
does your wife open up the mail yeah she
does and leaves it out for me and i
don't ever don't ever
open it i'm terrified of mail lately
because i think i probably got hit with
some crazy people told me they were
gonna
slit my throat or something so i go yeah
you know what i don't need to see what
people are sending me wait have you been
threatened before i don't remember me a
few times have you
yeah yeah and you get past it you go dan
dan you just give a trap flex um no i
get security
i get the police involved
the fbi involved in it but
who would have a problem with you well
it's not people who who it doesn't
happen that often but when it has
happened it's usually nicer people who
want to step it to the next they want to
get to the next level
[Laughter]
they feel like we'd be better off if we
were married and i have to tell them i'm
already married and oh
that kind of stuff oh so women see i get
guys i get some guys i got guys who want
to get married everybody likes i get
more guys than you do i bet yeah yeah
yeah
sports show but okay after the wedding
singer yes like you were i can't see
where women could fall in love with you
yeah yeah absolutely
i mean it's just i seem very patient you
know who uh i was just
[Laughter]
my wife always tells me my uh
she misses you know who she misses most
the first sixth month adam when we were
dating she's like that guy was
incredible
that guy was amazing i say yeah that guy
was he was but you're an actor bring it
back
you're not that good bring it back it
comes back like
right now i'm doing good i'm solid as a
rock yeah but you've been in hawaii
shooting a movie so you just got home
yeah but even on the phone i was
fantastic really yeah you got to work
the phone and even stay hot high good
level of sweetness
and uh yeah my my wife like thinks i'm
great right now but you give a good
phone
i have in the past uh not been perfect
i've had i've been quick you go quick on
the phone and then you find yourself you
get another call and you go that was a
two it was too quick
[Laughter]
we need more phone two do you ever time
it like yeah cause i remember calling in
when i'd be on the road and this is when
my wife was there with four kids really
young and i'm going to a steakhouse you
know i'm doing that to morton's or wolf
gangs or something and i have to
downplay she goes well you know what are
you doing tonight for dinner yeah uh i
don't know you know probably that's
funny probably get something you know
like in and out or something i don't
know
but but you have to downplay
i i'm the other way man my because i
don't do anything you know me i don't
leave too much and my wife like it was
uh chris rock's birthday
uh yesterday and i or two two days ago
and i just got home and
and i would and i was hanging out with
my wife and my kids and i said i'm
walking taking a walk with my wife and i
say yeah it's rock's birthday she says i
know i said they're having a dinner for
rock but uh and she goes you're skipping
that and i said i can't i i just got
home she goes you gotta go to rocks
what's the matter with you so she's kind
of cool with saying
stop being so psychotic and thinking you
got to be home and then i went and hung
out with rock for 20 minutes and it was
fun but how much do you act
at home
zero
hate uh i i i i kind of like uh i don't
know what happened man i used to be like
the the man everyone loved to see in the
house
and like i was so funny now
i i got to get something new going at
home they're not laughing as much as
they used to the kids they they're on
the phone talking to other kids
i come in and score i get a big laugh
from the children i'm like oh they like
me again and then i see him drift off
and you know what you need you need a
writer for your at-home dialogue
yeah
no not fritzy
yeah yeah certainly no no not not not
fritzy um did you ever wake up in the
middle of the night and write down
things
yeah i got a thing of notes on my phone
it says notes
and i write i got a million notes in
fact so many that i lose track of what
what i was talking about i don't i go
kind of like six words of what the joke
would be and i say this this and this
and uh and i get it in the next few days
i'm excited about it but when i look at
it a year later i'm like oh man i'm not
not sure what i was talking about best
idea you ever had in the middle of the
night
like
i can't remember a movie i mean a lot a
lot of things happen in the middle of
night i'm a lot of my jokes oh god i
wake up and write down and a lot of my
songs and stuff i i write down i come up
with a melody in the middle of the night
and
i'll do the uh
uh i'll sing into the phone and or i'll
grab a guitar and play something that
kind of thing middle of the night middle
of the night yeah yeah
uh he's adam sandler comedian founder of
happy madison productions and uh they
produced home team yeah that's the uh
sean payton did you see it yet
yes i did you were solid as a rocky
again well thank you
thank you uh by the way you're shooting
a movie with uh aniston
jenner anderson says hello yes yeah but
you know
we've gone past the halloween okay
just the other day on the set by the way
i just saw how i look it's ridiculous
i used to be so good-looking what
happened i don't know
when did you think it went bad the beard
is helping so much with protecting uh
the next swing
but the uh when did i start to go south
about 10 years ago i started getting
some rosacea on the face
i got red red crap on my face i'd be
like what happened
actually blend it
blend it and that's when it went bad i
was down and i was in africa and i kept
saying to my makeup girl what are you
putting on there
you're ruining my face and then i'd look
in the mirror i go what are you doing
you're putting some weird stuff on me
and she's like i'm using what i always
use i go no you're not and i kept
putting clothes in the mirror i was like
what the hell are you doing to me and
then i swear to god like three days
later i kept going what is this new crap
and then she's like it's your face now
you changed i was like i did in there
uh okay so aniston you were getting in
we were talking she was dancing the
other
day on the set this is like a week ago
and i said
what is that where'd you do that dan she
goes i didn't just go with it when i
when i was on stage with nicole like oh
that's right and i go and dan patrick
goes and dan pastor yeah yeah yeah she
knew that yeah well she called me the
sports guy yeah that's a damn patrick i
know but i didn't want to be just the
sports guy and you know nick schwartzen
went to yoga with her yeah nick's like
very tight with her and he is not a team
player now he didn't try to bring you
into it yes i i would have
i would have done yoga
you would have crushed it i i i would
have done yoga nobody's a better yoga
guy or runner than you yeah but then we
get done with yoga and then they went
and had did shots
they did a shot they were doing shots
and and danny p was not invited because
he was embarrassed you could put put him
oh i know
that many can beat schwartzen and you
got that i did but that's i always love
that sandler has only one piece of
advice don't end up in the news
on your sets like just don't do anything
stupid don't get arrested yeah yeah that
was i used to say that yeah
yeah that's have you ever been arrested
not fully arrested i i got oh i got
arrested when i came out to
uh i was living in van nuys i was 22. i
was driving
got pulled over
for speeding i do that a lot i calm down
a little bit but i i don't speed as much
my wife i drove her tesla the other
night those things were very fast but i
didn't get caught but um
when i was 22
i got a pulled over van nuys boulevard i
was doing uh
doing some whatever he goes license and
registration and i forgot my license at
home and he goes i gotta take you
and so i was in a holding cell cell for
for about four hours before my dumb
friends pick me up but some guy all i
remember is one guy kept saying i like
those sneakers to me and i said yeah
yeah he wanted and he wanted my sneakers
and i was
playing it tough i was like yeah
yeah i like them too
i kind of like them myself yeah man
they're staying on the feet but you
haven't been pulled over since you
became famous oh yeah i have but the
guys are nice to me sometimes autographs
yeah no have you put anybody in a
picture
that would be good yeah i got pulled
over one time when i was shooting the
longest yard by a cop with a mustache
okay here i am yeah here i am are you
going to watch the game on sunday very
excited about that i i my friend steve
behrens the guy you've met him over the
years he does all the animal training uh
on all he does all our dogs and
everybody in the movie he's the biggest
bengals fan and has been talking bengals
literally since i know him for like he
did a little nicki so i know him that
long oh well and he was always like well
the bangles this year and blah blah blah
and this year he's like i never heard
this guy so excited so
even though
i i live in los angeles i have a my
heart is pulling for and bobby boucher's
probably
uh connected with bengals quarterback
love so we'll see we'll see i'm kind of
are you hosting a party
uh i'm sure that we'll do it at my house
and people will show up i have no idea
man
the only thing is is i i just came home
from hawaii and i got to go to
uh france
for another
uh part of murder mystery two so like i
gotta kind of gotta hang with the family
so whatever they say i'm gonna do don't
take your shirt off and go swimming
again like you did in spain
i had i had
my wife saw the picture and she goes
have you seen adam with his shirt off
and i go i don't i don't think so she
goes well here it is yeah and i'm
thinking you're texting
my wife and yeah pictures
and i'm going what do you got and you
had your shirt on my shirt you had no
idea that the paparazzi was around no
knock up on me i was enjoying my
enjoying my swim with lochren of all
people and joe vesey who can't swim
one of the grossest things i've ever
seen i videoed the end of it i'll send
it to you
joe
dog paddling in the mediterranean my
shirt's off that's that's not great
looking but joe bessie dog paddling was
awful and he was like i never learned to
swim
i didn't need to i never needed that
he's a comedian joe he's got yeah peter
bessie's kid yeah peter bessie long time
nba by the way did you like the grateful
dead growing up did you did anyone here
like the dead no so you didn't like them
but when you listen to them now you know
they're great i i appreciate longevity
yes i i but i was just not a uh i'm not
a jam band
you know as you as you get older though
you realize how awesome that is you know
i when i was i didn't listen i listen i
list
fire on the mountain you know that one
lightning in the air
fire on the mountain right now that's
out western no it's not who got marshall
tucker band don't they oh okay yeah well
that's that yeah yeah you're right
you're right but this is this is
whatever your dad's good but every cool
kid in school had a dead uh shirt no
was that your ear or two or is that i
was more zeppelin in the stones we had
zeppelin in the stones how about you
guys did you have a t-shirt i had whole
notes and run dmc and beastie boys
it's as far as i got that okay yeah boys
nothing those badasses hauling oats
uh
okay danette's got one question each is
that okay yeah because normally yeah
they only get one all right that's
enough yeah paulie your one question for
uh adam's all right i'm gonna go a
little heavy um in the movie funny
people you are going to sleep and seth
roger's talking to you yeah and you said
something the lion's like truman try to
make my dad laugh for 40 years still
trying
did that come at all from your real life
growing up with your dad
that was i think that was uh apatow man
i i my dad laughed loved me my dad i
mean my dad was tough on me too but but
he loved me and he he was my number one
uh
laughing fan my father used to call me
up if i did good on saturday night live
and had a skit kill i'd be walking by
which wasn't every time but when i if i
had a skit
kill i'd be walking by the page desk
after and that one of the pages would go
adam adam adam and i'd be like hello and
i'd hear that a baby
yeah so he was tight my dad loved my
stuff
seating your question for uh sandman
this one might also be a little too
personal but we're just sort of talking
about it earlier when you get a big
check like that is that direct deposit
or is it actually a check that you have
to sign and deposit yourself oh yeah it
goes it just goes to the to the people
it does they just immediately disperse
i don't even get the joy of it i get
rare joy calls every like
six months i check in and i go how's the
sandman doing
all right
okay all right good all right sam and
getting back to his day
but do you get do you get a to a point
where it doesn't matter
like it does matter but it doesn't
matter what you're making
uh no i i i don't even think i don't
think too much about that stuff my i
know the the family's good the wife is
into that stuff what would you brothers
what would you want to buy that you
don't have i don't know but i got a i
got a condo in maui that was like a
great move i was down in uh i was for
the pandemic i was in maui and i was
having a we we rented a a place for a
week and then two weeks and then three
weeks because they're paying epic and
then i finally i i
i was like i think we'd be better off to
buy buy this place man we're dropping a
lot on this
rental and so then we bought the joint
and it's like the best place it's just
one bedroom one bath time
it's it's not huge but it's it's it's
it's not tiny but
what a hang kids get to hang hang with
their friends it's you going golf all
day long i got i'm into golfing i know
you sent me videos you look like but but
you look like you were lonely
yeah yeah yeah i don't i don't avoid too
many people
but when i go
i have like maybe five good holes in a
row and then it goes bad and then it
comes back
do people expect you to be happy gilmore
i have to i get called out literally
if i go to a new place it's a guarantee
on the opening tee where i mean it's
just
people come forward they're like looking
i'm like i gotta do this and
do this the guild wars swing and move on
uh todd your question for uh one from
one comedian to another yeah yeah how's
that going it's nice
now this is todd doesn't want you and
spade and schneider to write him like no
but you have to explain why because i
feel like it's like something especially
since i'm so
rookie and beginner at this that it
should be something that i come up with
so i can feel like i can actually write
and perform jokes like i feel like i'd
be cheating he doesn't want to take
your material if you would write
something for him he would rather bomb
with his stuff
yeah what i'm saying at least in the
beginning and then like when you're a
big shot then you could have a team of
writers and it doesn't matter who came
up with the job
down the line
yeah they don't see they don't see me
down the line with anything
but but that's like saying if you were
going to
be um
i don't know a great hitter and then you
had a batting coach do you not have a
batting coach
to help you as a hitter that's true yeah
so why not just someone's kind of giving
you tips well maybe maybe maybe getting
a few if somebody gave you a gem of a
joke say these guys dropped your killer
joke and it makes the crowd excited they
would never give me a good joke they
want me to bomb something no no no no no
we want you we want to laugh we were
they are in pain when you're up
we went to caroline's and he got up
there yeah
it wasn't good it's terrifying but you
know what but he's up there doing it
wait a minute
no we have we have sound this is actual
sound from caroline's after todd told a
joke
that's
very good very good
it's just not necessary is that mystery
it's very good
but the balls what about the that agony
of the silence it hurts the fat oh
terrible i just wanted to be a trap door
to fall down but the fact of the matter
is whether i bombed or they threw
tomatoes at me they booed me christmas
or whatever it is the fact that dan
pulled some strings and you guys because
of my affiliation with the show that i
got to be even one time at the comedy
store and that's cool you know anna
caroline's where the greats even though
you know i'm not like any of them but
just that i had a chance to into the csc
i think there might be a compromise here
okay what if todd wrote five minutes
right on his own that he came up with
and then somebody whether it's yourself
or another professional edited it and
said well this joke if you want the
punch line to be better you have to do
it this way or something maybe maybe it
was more edited that's different people
giving you thoughts of why why maybe
this could be funnier or or maybe you
got to get to it quicker a lot of times
in the beginning and i still have this
problem
i would babble too much to get to what i
thought was funny because you're so
nervous your head is spinning on the
stage crowd's watching you that you're
you're they're judging you you see that
you're losing them they're starting
conversations and you're panicked and
your head's spinning you don't get out
the way you did it in the bedroom
earlier right but but maybe there's that
waist a guy who's been doing it a while
could say you know you could just get to
this room and their point and rightfully
so is i'll make certain observations but
it's not necessarily a joke or a punch
line there it's almost like a seinfeld
kind of thing right he's actually funny
i'm like you know what this happens i
point out things that have happened in
my life that we could all relate to but
this has to be a joke at the end i think
it's just about landing on what what the
the last
bit of
you're talking about to make sure you're
telling the audience this is the funny
thing well the problem is it's
observational it's not observational
okay so all right bob that's the way
well maybe that's good for you maybe
you're going to do a drama eventually
you're going to write a drama and show
that's why that's where you and rock and
the guys come in i have the observation
then they could bring the action we'll
give you the ending yes
maybe todd is uh less
chris rock and more like david sedaris
right david sedaris
he uh where it's sort of observational
and just really funny stories and
telling funny stories is great but
there's not always a punch line there
yeah yeah yeah yeah what's your question
for sam he's being new he's coming up
with his own way exactly
my question i know you're huge
basketball fan so yes if you're on the
playgrounds in brooklyn or wherever you
want to be yes
your past and present you can pick four
guys to play with you putting the team
together and not necessarily the best
team ever the four you were past and
president would love to be on the same
team with on the playgrounds or wherever
you'd want to play basketball when i
used to play at rucker park
no uh uh i would go
i would say if i was just showing up
well i gotta pick juancho
juancho's on my team
because he's my friend and he's in the
movie that's coming out this summer and
he yes and you're in that too
but if it's just like normal people or
like sometimes
dr j
uh
coming up will be fun
um
who else
bernard
king yeah bernard king would be fun
uh
i liked uh well you you're a passer
you're a playmaker i like to get it to
other people so they finished colby
jordan
i'll get it to those two yeah yeah
that'd be fun too that'd be a good good
moment right there yeah i did show up
with some guys in my life though some
killers that i got to i lucked out by
the way i had this terrible groin injury
when i was
shooting uh who has a good groin injury
i got a bad groin injury well there's a
painful groiner and then there's the one
that you i couldn't even walk i stepped
out of the car with lochran my buddy i
get out of the car i go he's parking the
car i go i'll meet you in the restaurant
i get out of the car he pulls away all
of a sudden i was standing in the middle
of the road i go i can't take a step and
cars are going by man i'm like i can't i
can't walk right now my groin fell out
of the slide
start grabbing my leg and moving it
it was pathetic but and even with the
bad groin
some of the guys in the hustle all these
young guys that were going to play hoop
and they're all superstars in the nba
and i was like i can't miss that night
and i went and played with the bad groin
and played very uh slow
in fact somebody showed me an article
and in the article one of the guys who
played against us
they said how'd adam sandler play they
go he was all right but when he left
that's when the game got going
it's gracious i told these guys that
this movie hustle
is really good yeah it's cool it's
really good and you're going to fall in
love with anthony edwards anthony i was
just so funny minnesota timberwolves
he looks like he
it felt like he was an actor
he was so unhandsome dude he was so good
in that role but absolutely and that'll
be out towards the nba finals and
wancho's attend too and and beaubon and
and all the guys in it are funny as hell
and cool as hell but but um
that comes out in june
june yeah yeah around the playoffs yeah
yeah it's good you're right though
anthony is funny as hell on it anything
else to promote
no no but i'm happy to be here and
thanks and yeah i got to do something
about my face i can't believe what i'm
looking at
you know what i'm disgusting i'm i'm
sort of with you now the more
look at that even that shot is demented
wide and
should to come man we should have just
done a phone call
should have been assumed just
zoom's foggy enough to get away with me
thank you pathetic i love you love you
good to see you guys have a good super
bowl we're back after this
hey